boys and girls start your engines
because our next guest is racing into
history and inspiring other women and
young girls to dream big dream ginormous
people we're talking about 20 year old
professional race car driver that would
be the lovely haley deegan she's marking
she's making her mark as the only woman
did you hear that the only woman
competing in the srx racing series
co-founded by former nascar driver tony
stewart which debuted last year deegan
also races in the nascar truck series
yep she's a badass she joins
connecticut where she's already at the
speedway she's getting ready for the big
race that's tomorrow it's airing right
here on cbs and paramount plus which as
you know are both divisions of paramount
global that's us haley good morning to
you it's so good to see you
yeah good to see you too
so haley this is what i've been saying
about you all morning you're the only
woman out there on the track and i said
but she's not scared she's not scared
and she's ready please tell me i'm
correct you're not scared
definitely not scared i've done some
scarier stuff in my lifetime so we're
gonna have a lot of fun here
i'm talking about being the only woman
in the field of men
how that affects you does it inspire you
motivate you intimidate you
i've been like it's been like that my
whole life in racing growing up in
racing my dad didn't treat me any
differently i was one of the only girls
to do it when i was eight years old and
still one of the only girls to do when
i'm 20 now
yeah what did you see at eight that you
thought dad i want to do this
i think seeing him doing in racing and
competing at such a high level in the
motorsports world has really got me into
it when he made that transition from
motocross to off-road trucks there was
other little kids racing that were my
age and i just knew i wanted to try it
and the moment i got in a car i knew i
definitely did not want to get out of it
haley many people don't realize that
racing is both mental and physical so
how do you prepare for that
when you get behind that wheel
yeah there's a lot of preparation that
goes into the races because there's so
many races throughout the year so you
kind of get in a system of it whether
it's what you eat how you're training
how you're hydrating a lot of times in
these cars when you start getting on
some of the bigger tracks hot days out
there it could be 130 140 degrees inside
the car so it definitely takes a toll on
your body
you know haley uh when i saw you were
joining us this morning i thought of my
father-in-law and i thought of my cousin
petey in north carolina who were devoted
nascar fans
and i see you know you're on a shorter
track there's a little more dirt
involved what is the biggest difference
between srx and nascar and and why
should somebody be tuning in on saturday
night to watch
yeah i got my start in stock car racing
on these short tracks where it's just
super fun super competitive uh close
tight racing and as i started moving my
way up the ranks we got to some bigger
tracks but coming back to the srx series
and competing on these small tracks
makes it entertaining you got a lot of
talented drivers out there drivers who
have been racing for far more years than
i have and then mixing it up with them
is always fun so we're going to have a
lot of fun here at stafford and i can
guarantee it's going to be a good show i
have to tell you haley i'm just in awe
of you because at eight years old i was
playing with barbies and i was scared of
bugs i'm still scared of bugs so what is
your ultimate dream when it comes to
racing i'm curious about that and if you
face barriers because you were female in
this sport
my ultimate goal when it comes to racing
is to keep moving up the ranks in the
stock car world competing at the highest
level and being competitive running up
front getting good finishes but
it's a lot of fun it's a lot of work i
enjoy it a lot though so there is some
challenges that come with it and i feel
like the hardest part is the pressure
that i put on myself i feel like i hold
myself to such a high standard that i
feel it the most just from myself so i
think that there's a lot of pressure
definitely from the outside that affects
that but you got to perform under
pressure
yeah nothing tops the pressure you put
on yourself i so get that haley deegan
we are cheering you on congratulations
congratulations to you
thank you i appreciate it you guys
better head out to stafford to come out
for the race this weekend
we better do that thank you haley